-I know you have three nieces.
Were they excited to see you i
that "My Little Pony" shirt?
-So, they haven't seen me yet,
and I'm like this crazy,
weird mythical Uncle John...
-Yeah.
-...that when I show up
I'm a cartoon character 'cause
they see me on television
and they haven't been
able to see
movies like "Trainwreck" yet
-Right.
-So, this'll be the first time
they go to see crazy Uncle Joh
on a movie screen.
-Oh, that'll be very exciting.
-Usually when I come to visi
or they come to visit me,
I literally assume the rol
of a tackling dummy.
It's unleashing --
which is karma 'cause I wa
just such a crappy kid.
So, basically,
they climb all over me
and it's a bunch
of wrestling around
and I try to absorb as muc
of their energy as I can,
and their parents
just disappear.
I get totally ghosted
by my brothers
and their significant others
and they're just in the corner
kicking with a drink
and be like, "Fine, you take
care of them for a while."
But I honestly really --
I love them to death.
I look forward to seeing them.
We're gonna hang out
on Thanksgiving.
And it's, like -- I love
the perspective of young people.
It'll be interesting to se
how they --
-They'll be very honest.
-They certainly will.
-I feel their reviews of movie
are really --
-"Uncle John, why did you suck?"
[ Laughter ]
"Well, eh."
-[ Laughs ]
Uh, so this is very rare, bu
sometimes guests are on the show
and they tell a story
about another celebrity.
-What have I done?
-Well, that's the thing.
We had Sean Casey on,
who was an ex baseball player,
and he told us a story about one
night he was at a bar with you
and he asked you to --
what's the move called?
-It's called a chop.
-A chop.
He asked to be chopped.
-He did.
-By you.
-Which seems like a thing yo
would only ask
if multiple drinks had be drank.
-Yes. That is correct.
-And you being a professional,
did you say to him,
"Hey, man, I can't do it"?
-I feel like I can be honest
with you guys.
-Yeah.
-Okay, so the setting
is the Major League playoffs
The Major League Baseball
playoffs.
The Red Socks are playing
the Tampa Bay Rays.
I just so happen to
live in Tampa
and was rooting for the Rays
that year.
Don't hold it against me.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So, I know Sean
for a long time.
He's staying at the team hotel
He's like, "Hey, man,
come on down, say hello."
Saying hello
to Sean and Tim Wakefield
and myself at that time
was pretty much
drinking the bar out of
everything that was liquid
-Yeah, yep.
-Yes.
So in the height
of our dysfunction,
he's like, "Hey, man, you know
like the Ric Flair chops?
I want you to chop me."
I'm like, "Dude, you don't
You definitely
don't want that to happen.
But I did not say it as sober.
I was like, "Damn, bro.
No, bro."
-[ Laughs ]
-"Don't. Don't go there."
So, eventually,
they really forced me to.
Like, both Sean and Tim
wanted to be chopped.
I'm like, "Okay.
What's the safe--
what's the best way?
You guys have to chop me first."
So I take my shirt off.
As you saw in the clip,
that's something I do.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, if I had your body,
I'd do it, too.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not judging. Yeah, yeah.
I'm not judging.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, Sean hits me.
And a chop is an open-hand
strike on the breastplate,
so it makes a good sound.
I'm mic'd and I have clothes on,
but it makes a good sound.
[ Smack! ]
-Yeah, very helpful
for in the ring.
-Yes, because
it's the audible crack.
Like, it makes that crack-
sound, but it hurts like hell.
So he winds up and hits me
He doesn't know how to do it
Okay, fine.
Tim winds up,
and he's a pitcher.
I thought I'm gonna get creamed.
He didn't know how to do it.
And Sean's like, "Ah, do me!
And before
he could say "Do me!",
like, he had his chest out
From -- pun intended --
left field, whack!
And look at this.
I put a frying pan on his chest.
So I hit him, and he goes,
"Ow!"
And he exposed his back,
so I'm like, "Boom!"
"Ow!"
[ Laughter ]
-And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that literally led to thre
dudes holding a royal rumble
in the lobby of
the Red Socks' team hotel...
-Oh, my God.
-...at, like,
undisclosed AM time.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't think --
I don't know if they made it
to the game the next day.
-Yeah. I'll have to look bac
at those box fares.
-I know they didn't win
the series,
so Red Socks fans,
I'm very sorry.
I may have sabotaged the team.
-You did some chopping.